My name is Noam Schwartz.
I'm from Similar Web.
Similar Web is a web company
that helps marketers grow and
win in the online marketing world.
We basically solve the major problem
of understanding what your competitors
are doing in digital world,
what's working for them,
what's not working for
them how do they go?
What people are doing on their
website and the mobile app?
And we working with Fortune
500 companies, with startups.
We really love to help people grow and
win in digital world.
Before joining Similar Web,
I was CEO of a company called Tap Blog.
We were actually competing with Similar
Web and then Similar Web acquired us.
I became head of innovation and
head of US operations for Similar Web,
and since then, I'm working with a lot
of companies, advising them about their
marketing strategy, about how to win and
how to grow, and having a lot of fun.
When you're starting with social media,
you've gotta have a goal in mind.
What exactly are you trying to do?
Don't just try to do social media for
the sake of it,
because you want to get more users,
you want to get them to buy something,
you want to retain them,
you want to remind them that your there.
You want to promote an event,
what do you want to do?
Then after you decide
what you want to do,
you need to be associate it with
the content that your creating.
And I can't stress it enough
how important it is to
correlate your voice, the content,
and the actual platform.
So let's say that you're a small startup
that is trying to sell clothing.
Does it make sense to you to be present
on LinkedIn, and keep updating there?
The medium sometimes is more
important than the actual message.
One other thing is localization.
Let's say that you have a huge
user base in Brazil or in China or
in India or in Russia.
There are specific social
networks that exist there and
they are more popular the Facebook.
You want to have presence there
because you can acquire a lot of
users from there.
Obviously you need to use the language
that they speak in those countries.
But the ROI on using those social
networks can be amazingly high.
Another thing is to treat web
sites like Stack Overflow, or
GitHub, or even Reddit like social
network because if you have a presence
there that you keep maintaining and
you keep posting interesting stuff,
you're educating or
entertaining you users.
People will keep exploring who is
this user, who is the president,
who is the company behind
this amazing social present?
And you'll get even more value for
your money, for your efforts than
you will get on Twitter, on Facebook or
or wherever you're being present today.
One of the most important things when
you're doing your content marketing
strategy is first of all, don't look
at the processes creating content or
creating inventory.
That's a recipe for failure, because you
don't want just to create content for
the sake of it.
You want to create stuff that
people will actually like.
And the best way to do
something like that
is to try to imitate
the way a newspaper works.
You want to get interesting content.
Something that will
keep people intrigued.
Something that people
would like to read.
And then produce it.
Don't measure your content
creators based on number of folds.
Measure them based on
the engagement that they can create
after they published their content.
And not all the will get the same thing,
the same number of likes, clicks,
whatever you would like
to measure it with.
But eventually,
that's the best steady way
to measure the success of
the content marketing strategy.
Another example of great content
marketing strategy is Buffer,
for example.
Buffer is a B2C2B company basically that
gives you the ability to schedule your
Tweets, your Facebook updates, and
schedule your for sure activity.
And their blog, which is one of
the most popular blogs in tech,
has nothing to do with their product.
It has nothing to do with productivity,
with being transparent with your
employees, with being a better person.
And people that don't even
know that they have a company,
that they have a product,
keep following this blog.
And this works amazingly.
One of the things that
we do at Similar Web and
we did in [INAUDIBLE] is following
the activity of companies.
Following what's going
on on the internet.
And the best way to understand
what you want to write about,
what kind of content you want to create.
Just checking it out.
So, one of the things that
we do at Similar Web,
really to create content
that engage people is
to track the trends that are currently
happening on the internet.
If it's the Sony breach, or
if it's Netflix, what people
are watching on Netflix today,
new products, new investments.
The Pope's visit to New York, whatever!
And we write blog posts about it,
we create content about it,
because we see what people care about.
And then if people see the content
we create and they want to share it,
because they want to feel smarter,
because they want to
educate their friends or
they want to entertain them that's
a huge win with every locals like that.
Let's imagine if we really
start a we need to be scrappy.
We need to not use
a lot of resources and
get a lot of traction,
a lot of, we need huge ROI's.
So, we invest a lot of time in
creating the content and crafting it.
But that investment in understanding
what people care about,
understanding the specific medium, the
specific timing and the specific context
that we're going to release this
content is everything for us.
Another example is.
Before they sold and also after,
they have an amazing blog.
They are the best in
entertaining people.
I think the blog is called
Sriracha Tales or something like that,
and they are using it for
rants about food,
and just bragging about
new stuff that they did.
And they entertain their users
in such a way that you feel
better when you're sharing
some of the content.
This is amazing.